les petits princes est avant tout une
comédie dramatique avec tout ce que ça
représente un enjeu pour ces mecs là qui
veut devenir professionnel justement et
en même temps c'est une comédie tout
l'univers des jeunes entre eux je
voulais vraiment à ce que ce soit assez
frais avec ses thématiques qui sont
l'amour les premières expériences
sexuelles les premières relations
amicales des mégots jeunes ça chambre ça
dans tous les sens et à tours 1 m pour
vanner que ce que nous fait la seprim
soieries cosby show
le film y parle de tout ça pour être des
adolescents leur révolution
ça parle de fou on n'est pas uniquement
concentré sur un stade avec des joueurs
il ya toute une histoire à côté c'est
une histoire d'avenir de passion dans
vie sans film d'amour ça se cherche
entre mecs et nanas
je sais pas ce qui se passe mais là je
sens que c'est notre année à tous les
deux
le centre de formation de foot c'était
pour moi vraiment une rencontre entre
différents milieux
une vraie communauté avec tous les
échantillons de vie possible ça donne
quelque chose de très vrai on parle du
fou qui nous parle aussi que minutes du
street art
pour moi c'était quelque chose qui
justement une diversité du relief par
rapport à cet univers
ça va être un terreau générationnel je
pense autant les filles autant les
garçons autour du jeune que les lieux
parce que c'est la vie